here's the question that okay back to
your other thing like when you are
smiling but you don't feel like it
how have you accepted that about
yourself because i like the truth of
people
i like the colors and the light and the
dark and the in between the churroscuro
if you will
i like i like to keep it real
but i don't know who i am
i don't know i don't i don't know what
exists outside of the
paper and pen and the recordings that i
make like that was that's who i
have
been comfortable with the whole time
right so i think that that is the real
you in those writings and with that pen
and with the guitar is that a part of
you for sure those are my stories like
that's that is me
but i can
i can't exist my entire life as a song
right like the song's over after three
minutes and 15 seconds so i have to
what do i do with the rest of the 24
hours that i have to exist it's
interesting to know that's your
perspective
because um i like you i like you so much
and
if there's any consolation like i had to
eat a bowl of macaroni and cheese
because i had a hard day at work because
you know i i'm still learning on this
job and i i just eviscerate myself all
the time
so i understand yeah but don't
don't let yourself like get in the way
of the things that people love about you
which is like
you know we're
we're scared to have a learning
curve in our life because we're
comments make us feel like we're
supposed to have it right at that very
moment and
what they don't realize is that
life is growth like if someone has a
desire to grow and they they show it and
we should encourage it it's odd that i
don't know sometimes the world
disappoints me i i don't i don't mean to
bring that into this i know my publicist
is back they're just like what are you
doing you're supposed to talk about
nails your publicist is probably like
i just my aesthetic eye is killing me i
gotta redo this hand okay please um
by the way
okay so if you can see those things that
me and your daughter are you gonna be
able to see that in yourself because
everything you just said about all of us
i see in you
excuse me hold on
i'm sorry sorry i'm so sorry
but i had to do that
i um
i really hope so you know i wanna i
wanna stick around and see how the story
ends so i think you're holding the pen
i think you are the writer
yeah speaking of writing
how do you like that for a segway
dovetail maybe i don't suck at this job
so badly
will you tell me about this book hotel
diablo yeah i am a huge lover of graphic
novels i think it's an escape into a
fantasy world
not just
leaving it up to your mind for those who
can't read words and put visuals to them
but it kind of does does both there's no
superheroes and capes in this comic
there's no
i mean i think it's almost just like a
reflection of what we've been talking
about when you get like
dark and deep does megan go like oh
honey or she like lighten up oh no
she's the most compassionate person ever
but i think like my dark is just so dark
she's like oh god
like but no she's she's
super compassionate she's the nicest
person i've ever met and like she
she loves me for me and all my crazy so
i
what tactic does she use
to sort of
open one up that we could all benefit
from because we're all trying to do that
for each other exorcism
[Music]
some real demons in there that we gotta
get out
i have literally reagan upstairs like
can someone bring her down so i can show
and prove can i ask how you guys met
did you get set up on a date
we were filming a movie and
uh which i which ironically i took
because
the only the only reason i took the
movie was because they were like your
scenes with megan fox and i was like
i'll take the movie and um
but i
stayed outside the trailer and
my gut is
always right and i'm grateful for it
because
for some reason i knew she would invite
me to lunch and then all of a sudden
someone came over and they were like
megan wants to know if you want to have
lunch in a trailer
and i was like
oh my god i'm so surprised yeah
absolutely i had like a whole bag packed
like
like and uh i went in there
and uh
she said
how do you feel and i said i'm lost and
she said let's find you and i was like
it killed me i was like she i mean she
she was cupid and i was i was
you got hit by her arrow
right in the
um by the way i have someone here who
wants to visit
oh
thank you you mentioned exorcist
thank you daniel
oh my god hi
should we do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i i relate
i feel you so every morning um reagan
greets us in the uh writer's room
because this was what my daughter wanted
for halloween and then i bought it and i
brought it and then she was like okay i
changed my mind it's too scary
so now she's been living in our office
well since you're here
[Applause]
keep being that keep breaking down those
walls
keep making your music keep feeling your
feelings smile when you want to don't
when you don't want to make that be
okay for other people maybe your
discomfort will be
a gateway and an open door and a bridge
for someone else
who might feel that feeling but doesn't
know what to do with it that's that's
why i named it undone because i was like
you're not you shouldn't be done like
changing you shouldn't be done evolving
and it's like as simple as
nail polish can seem it's still like
action of meditating or breathing is
also simple it's like all i have to do
is breathe but it is wild like to see
what breathing like deep breaths or like
those things
yeah yeah it's absolutely blew my mind
what that
one word has done
you shouldn't you shouldn't be done i i
i watched my father change like right
before he passed because he wasn't done
and like he wasn't
scared to like
make a step even in the age that he was
and in the state that he was and like
the coolest thing my dad did i remember
like
for so many years i hid my tattoos from
him i had been tattooed since i was 14
years old but
uh and i revealed them when i was 18 or
19 something like that like
i mean he got a plateful i was like i
have a baby on the way and also
[Laughter]
he was like
oh my god
[Laughter]
and uh but he was on the hospital bed
and like
like
lifted up
the gown
and he had a tattoo on his hand
and i was like it was a jesus tattoo of
course but uh
i i thought it was so rad he wasn't
done becoming the person that he wanted
to be until it was his time and that's
maybe why his time came because like he
finally he
there was one last step he had to take
and he took it and
that was fire i think we have a lot to
talk about like with our dads by the way
i just can't stress to about what my
publicist is back there thinking i can't
like pass out by the way
she's gonna be like
i just it's like because the funniest
part this is this is also funny i go
she looked at me before i walked out
here she was like
all right based off of the last 15
minutes from being around you
do you really want to go out there and i
was like dude i'm not going to bring any
of this out there
i'm
sorry to leave you out i'll do respect i
never want to see you again ever in my
life
she just wants to be loved too please
stand up with me yeah of course i have
to tell you
i was excited to meet you and i thought
that i really
liked you she's like and now yeah
i never want to see you and now
i have to tell you i
love you
[Music]
you